time travel no
inversion it did take me some time to
read it uh as we kept going um
uh but uh just to try to under just try
to understand the rules of
of inversion and on a page but just
reading it i just
i could i can really see the character
though which was
exciting me to be put in a world like
this a character like this and um
and different from you know a spy
thriller action thriller character you
know i saw a human being
in the writing and which got me excited
to play a human being in a
in a film like this so yeah definitely
jumped off the page it was exciting
john david washington stars and
christopher nolan's time-bending spy
thriller tenet well that's from here
hasn't happened yet anytime you you you
start a film you're trying to figure out
what's the tone
and and for me with this material with
action in particular it feels like if
you can keep a grounded tone if you can
make it plausible for
the audience if you can give them a
reason to believe in it
the thrill ride aspect of the film just
becomes much more exciting
so particularly when you have science
fiction concepts coming in
i just felt like if we could keep it
really grounded and really real and
really in the world of a grounded sort
of
espionage thriller that would give the
audience a more exciting
and immersive experience they'd really
be there with john david's character
going through these extraordinary events
one extraordinary event for washington
was overcoming his intense fear of
heights
my fear of heights and having to jump
off of a building in mumbai
that was probably the chief of them the
hardest but um i it was a a breakthrough
because i am not
as terrified i'm just now scared of
heights but not terrified so that's good
we're going in the right direction he
hit it very well he's a very fine
actress
i just thought he wasn't quite taking
direction that evening
later it emerged that uh he had a little
nervousness going on with the heights
but uh
i wasn't very aware of that when we were
filming he was incredibly professional
and
did everything as needed and and added
so much more to
all of the physicality of the character
as well as the characterization
obviously
yeah chris was very patient that evening
on the uh when i had to jump off
the so let's just say uh there was more
text than usual in that particular
instance based off of performance not
technical stuff so uh
i wasn't taking a note very well because
i was scared so
it seemed like i was i'd receive it i
tell him like yeah i got it
but i would do the same thing i did
before so uh you'd say you got it with
the thousand-yard stair
sort of like something going on behind
me or yeah
yeah yeah so we got it eventually
fantastic is out now in select theaters
across the u.s
one of the first movies to head back to
cinemas during the coronavirus global
pandemic
anytime people are really keen to see
something you've done
that's obviously thrilling as a
filmmaker but obviously we're hopeful
that people will be patient with the
rollout of the film
and wait for it to to come to their area
the studio i think is doing a remarkable
job of slowly and safely rolling out the
film across the world
as theaters are able to open
and you know hopefully people can be
patient with the with the release of the
film
um the the theaters are uh they've
committed to the studio to play it for a
long period of time and
and uh so we'll we'll be there for a
while for people to discover in their
own time
well i've seen too much well we'll try
and keep up